tôi chỉ mất một phút để dạy con bò
và em bé của tôi đã có thể trường sau năm ngày tập rồi
các bà hãy tập ngay cái bài tập này Cho em bé
để giúp Cho em bé của mình nhanh biết bò
nhanh biết trường hơn nhá
một mô phỏng động tác chân khi mà em bé bò nha
à mình sẽ làm cái này từ 10 Cho đến 15 lần nha
một ngày khoảng 2 đến BA lần
sau đó thì mình sẽ chuyển sang động tác Tay
mô phỏng động tác Tay khi mà em bé bò đấy
giúp Cho
Tay của em bé cực kỳ linh hoạt và em bé sẽ biết vận dụng
Tay như thế nào khi bò
động tác thứ BA là mình sẽ kết hợp Tay và chân à
Tay và chân đó để em bé biết là a
khi mà bò thì mình sẽ kết hợp Tay và chân như thế này đây
đó mình sẽ đổi bên nhá đổi bên Cho bên Kia này đó
đấy một ngày như thế này từ 2 Cho đến BA lần nhá
chụm 2 chân lại em bé đẩy này đấy em bé đẩy
đấy em bé đẩy đấy em bé đẩy này
đấy em bé đẩy này đấy em bé đẩy này bò bò bò bò
음 뭐해
wacht wacht wacht
هاي هاي هاي هاي